that's the focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
now
Obama thought Democrats had the market
cornered on Hispanic voters
liberals think so little of
to be back with all of you
Dios de bandiga
to have one thing to say
there you go there
all right
[Music]
there you go my sister-in-law
um she is uh Latino and uh her family uh
I love hanging out with them and
practicing my espanol
diversity of this community
is Mercury
because both parties have gotten a lot
wrong over the years about this country
it's very diverse Latino Community now
remember the old 2016 consensus about
what the GOP had to do to attract
Hispanic voters nobody in the Republican
Party knows what Donald Trump's
immigration policy is other than that
it's hard line which turns off Hispanic
voters Hispanics have been trending
Republican for years what has turned
them around has been this hard-line
immigration even having this
conversation sends a powerful signal
they're doing high fives in the Clinton
campaign right now when they hear this
right now when they hear this
he was talking about building the wall
and Jeb was wrong well we all know all
of this was false and although Biden won
the Hispanic vote by 21 points 59-38
that was down significantly from
Hillary's 38-point Advantage meanwhile
Trump surged broadly among Hispanics
gaining about 10 points from 2016 to
2020.
and all along what Republicans needed
was a GOP that would fight for the
working people be tough on crime and
unnecessary and frankly stupid Wars and
stand up for conservative values
and if you didn't know just how
important Hispanic Americans are in our
life and our politics well just consider
this in 2022 nearly 35 million Latinos
will be eligible to vote or 14 of the
nation's eligible voters in recent
elections in Arizona they represent one
in four of all voters and Nevada One in
five in Florida one in five and here in
Texas three and ten
although Hispanics still prefer the
Democrat Party let's face it by about a
two to one margin that margin has been
slowly and steadily shrinking and now
Democrat Consultants well they're
finally worried Pew research is
reporting that 77 of Latino registered
voters are dissatisfied with the way
things are going in the country
54 disapprove of Biden's job performance
80 say the economy is a very important
issue for them and the other top issues
include Health Care at 71 and violent
crime and education both at 70 percent
so no wonder Hispanics in Florida a very
large Cuban American Community there are
flocking to support the re-election of
Governor Ron DeSantis he has a seven
point Advantage among the Latino group
over Charlie Crist and more Hispanics
supported his Martha's Vineyard migrant
flights then opposed his Martha Martha's
Vineyard migrant flights so we're seeing
the same Dynamic by the way play out
here in Texas with Republicans gaining
among Hispanics in key parts of the
state
just take a look at these border
counties and their rightwood rightward
lean between 2016 and 2020. and in
Arizona Republican Senate candidate
Blake Masters is making a huge push for
Hispanic voters Masters is forging into
Democratic territory
by opening field offices and
predominantly Latino neighborhoods
people are sick of this right you make
energy expensive you make everything
expensive Masters economic and social
message resonance shows him tied with
incumbent Mark Kelly who a few months
ago Democrats thought was just a lock
for re-election to the Senate
and in Nevada Democrats are fearing that
Senator Cortez masto will lose to Adam
laxalt as nearly every poll shows her
behind and continuing to lose Latino
support wow
now all this makes perfect sense
you see Hispanics don't like getting
lied to any more than any other
demographic group
and Democrats have been lying a lot
non-stop frankly
during Trump they lied about Russia
collusion then they lied about how
School shutdowns were really necessary
then they lied about inflation
they just have a problem telling the
truth and all of it affects the Hispanic
Community as much as any other perhaps
even more so community in the United
States
they lied about how soft on crime
policies like bail reform would lead to
better results instead of course it's
led to a surge in crime that hurts
Hispanic communities
they lied about how the Border was under
control didn't you love that which has
led to of course Hispanic deaths from
Fentanyl and overcrowded classrooms
difficult for parents and kids to deal
with
they lied about needing to shut down
businesses during covet doing enormous
damage to our growing class of Hispanic
entrepreneurs
and they lied about who's to blame for
these ridiculously high energy prices
blaming poor gas station owners that was
nice Joe Biden
Democrats are so desperate to hold on to
power that they'll even lie to conceal
the true medical condition of their own
candidates
Joe Biden and John fetterman
now after last night's sad performance
by fetterman in the debate with mehmed
Oz the Shameless Fanatics at the view
are still defending his Fitness for
office
it was really strange to me that he
chose to bully a stroke victim yeah
right like he obviously was bullying him
we know that fetterman's cognitive
abilities have not been compromised it's
about expression right that has been
compromised
now it's bullying to ask people
questions that's today's Democrat Party
why would anyone choose voluntarily
today with their track record and that
kind of comment to be a member of this
party
now Hispanic Americans as diverse and
multifaceted as they are they want what
we all want
they want a government that works for us
not against us
the fact is more Hispanics are beginning
to see what Reagan democrats saw in 1980
that the country that they love
is better LED by conservatives than by a
party that deceives and disrespects them
day in and day out
so on Election night in 2020 when so
many Republicans were in distress of
course about the results that that were
happening
I saw a positive trend when we look at
Florida the Coalition that the
Republicans have been able to put
together in that state
is really something that they should try
to replicate as much as possible going
forward up and down the East Coast with
a a strong contingent of of seniors
Latinos young professionals
African-Americans Florida is the future
for the Republican Party
the Florida model the Texas model where
Republicans have been working overtime
to engage Hispanics on the issues they
care most about but especially along the
border
the Outreach is working look at what
happened in Virginia last year Glenn
Younkin he made a concerted effort to
reach the Hispanic Community including
on the school issue Hispanic language
radio ads television ads turns out that
Hispanics do not want their kids to
focus on gender fluidity in the
classroom any more than any other
parents do
we're seeing similar efforts all across
the country
but we aren't yet finished we have a lot
of work to do
but the old Canard that somehow populism
and Hispanic Outreach don't mix well
that's been proven wrong
and the vicious lie that populist
Republicans don't want to work with
Hispanic voters has been totally
discredited
our populist movement was never limited
to Rural America because it's designed
to improve life for all Americans of all
ethnic backgrounds in all 50 states
for a long time the media refused to
believe that populist Americans who
support the Maga movement would have
anything in common with Hispanic voters
but they were wrong
so I say
vamanos
is puede and that's the angle hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else